les chiens n'ont pas ce que je vais vous
dire un truc regardez c'est vrai
regardez le meilleur sondage le meilleur
sondage ait eu des sondages ipsos pas
demi yaris est allé tellement le
meilleur sondage qui a début vers ip
classe à 4 le public de tpm perea et 3
km 78 des socialo d'eric zemmour à 7%
fin pas au vote wins le plus de tpm paie
donc aux sondages qu'on a fait tous les
soirs près lorsqu'il avait bu et qu'elle
avait vu jean luc mélenchon trait aux
comptes et pme et aussi la 21 95
personnes me le donnait aussi aux gens
n'ayant plus des mêmes nous les mecs te
dise quand même fou d'autres sondages
suis désolé mais quand même
les séries regardez même temps la voyez
où jean lassalle et non mais là la vrai
de vrai truc ont été très bons c'est
valérie pécresse valérie pécresse alors
justement on va revenir sur chacun des
candidats nathalie arthaud elle a fait 0
56 c'est comme à l'école ils mettent ça
pour l'umq
ses côtés de m 0,5 et les gmi 0,5 pour
lancre parce que j'aurai d'ancrer la
feuille micheline atteint hier
téléboutiques philippe poutou il a fait
0 77 et alors fallait en fait il ya un
mec de plus qu'à voter pour finir bien
un gars de pulse mais moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est trouver ces gars là
parce que j'ai rien savoir combien ça
représente et celles qui arrivent après
non mais qu anne hidalgo a admis d'algos
1,75 elle un score de boulangerie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de bons chocolats à l'instar de
2.75 souffert sans déconner étant à moi
tu auras l'abonné derrière de fou
nicolas dupont aignan suit la machine
tous les ans il vient ce qu on fait
pareil debout là aussi mais me ce qui
lui ferait tous les ans et la deux voilà
il a eu deux bons mais il n'est pas
remboursé pour tous ceux qui sont moins
de 5 % il a devancé les trois jeunes
explique ray ça tout à l'heure si la
merci on rappellera
fabien roussel parti gaulliste qui était
venu me voir 2,28 là ça commence à
décoller vrai on dernière j'avais
vraiment l'impression d'être à l'école
c'est quand ils donnent les notes de la
plus basse ah oui tu sais et tap qu'une
envie c'est pas d'avoir ta copine et moi
le problème c'est que j'avais toujours
accompli en premier je la voyais que dès
que la prof à la reine était lavé la
copie sous moi j'ai une relation lettres
et j ai fait je savais je n'ai je peux
la prendre tout de suite nora sera donné
après et jean lassalle dégâts
3-13 c'est la révélation ouais ah oui un
méchant la salle c'est la règle a signé
des nations unies s'est aussi incroyable
à 3 23 3% après yannick jadot bon lui
match qui n'a alors je vous explique si
vous faites plus de 5% on vous rembourse
votre campagne si vous faites moins de
5% c'est vous qui payez votre campagne
ça veut dire que là tu prend une tannée
mon frère non seulement tu fais un score
de merde opus ut fait chier pendant deux
ans et en plus ça coûte une bonne cette
plainte a dit ça veut dire que tu dois
prendre un crédit pour payer la campagne
que quand que tu as fait c'est un truc
de fou alors si une énorme raz sera donc
à yannick jadot europe ecologie les
verts 4 63 4 63 c'est un score de g20
c'est quand tu as pris deux paquets de
granola
textile tout ça valait alors valérie
pécresse
a du bol de cendres et soixante dix est
ce que tu te rends compte quand tu es
chez toi tu es dans ton cul j'étais avec
des amis
c'est entre 10 et 12 mais bon même qu'un
soin au début tu es tu prends 4 78 deux
frères c'est une arche oui mon frère
sa veux dire toute la journée tu es
comment as-tu voir ce phénomène comme tu
fais 4 78 mais 4,78 c'est un jeu 2d en
fait à la base c'est un truc de fou elle
a fait 4 78 eric zemmour
7,07 celgene bond de la politique
zéro décès
on nous a caché les couilles pendant
deux ans
les plateaux mon frère il a loué le
trocadéro louée par ses airs a fait
s'est ouverte
à de l'argent mais sans déconner cette
mon frère salaires dont vous il est
remboursé teddy il a fait plus d'en face
à bah
alors valérie pécresse j'en parle même
pas c'est à dire hier cent fois plus de
monde pour garder patraque c'est un truc
de ouf et ya des gens ils ont dû mettre
face à messi qui est cette personne
c'est fini c'est quoi et qui sont ces
gens après alors lui ça c'est ça jean
luc mélenchon mushkin c'est les français
aux jo
toujours à habas et de la salle de la
filature jean luc mélenchon toute la
journée parce que jean luc mélenchon et
j'avais les scores jean luc mélenchon
mais ce corps qui fut vite parce qu'il
ya des mecs voilà qui font des sondages
à la sortie des urnes croyons pas qu'ils
demandent aux gens tout
est à 16 à 11 heures 14 heures il a 18
16 heures il a 19
18h01 avant
minuit la bataille toujours de plus il
est à 40
à
alors ça ramène la même issue de la pnj
21,95 de malfaçons lire j'en sais pas ça
ça de ma mère sur la ligne c'est un truc
de mecs il a jamais été aussi haut avec
lui c'est un truc de fou parce que l'on
ne croyait perdus il est à 12% comme
quoi m les mecs là c'est pas une remonte
à nahla qui l'a fait je vous dis et ça
fait 2 ça fait deux élections je l'avais
dis moi ya cinq ans j'avais dit deux
semaines de plus aimés enchantée au
deuxième tour et là je pense que douze
jours de plus un militaire il avait été
c'est un truc de fou ici il ya manqué ça
tu sais votre scène c'est lui qui doit
être que plus de plus venez rendre mais
c'est vrai qu'il fait demain je ferai
une émission d vénère
de m'assurer une émission d vénère un
genre ceux qui ont fait 400 tu vas y
aurait déjà des gens qui étaient voilà
de la france et insoumis et je ferai
également ce que j'appelle l'émission
d'être outré l'émission dépêtrer avec
l'émission des traîtres est parce que
tous ceux qui ont quitté marine le pen
pour aller chercher des mots ah ouais
mais les côtés mais c'est dommage mais
c'est
dommage mais ce match du collège
normal je veux faire une séquence la
séquence des retraites
il est aussi dommage c'est la séquence
d'être très serré oblige et je le fais
après bon alors marine le pen elle est
passée
commence mon frère est ça veut dire
cette nuit elle a dormi elle est au
deuxième fois c'est une tête je me
réveille dommage c'est
un truc de fou c'est vrai et et voilà
moi je me suis moi je vois ce que bon
après un moment j'en avais ras le cul de
tous âges c'est sûr il y avait les
charlots sur s'est vite évident à son
délire aussi des bidasses à eux toujours
un bonheur c'est quand même alors et
c'est pour ça que moi j'aime ses limites
en pleine élection
présidentielle a le monde attend les
élections nous on est tranquille on met
des bouddhas ces gens qui veulent
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
mélenchon il n'y a pas de notion pas de
jouer ce soir les garçons hors du temps
modernes et c'est toute la journée yeux
et des animaux les animaux de la 8 après
il ya animaux adoptés et après ils me
lasse après voilà tranquille à parle de
tout est à nous et à noter qu'elle
était là pour
ça et on tuera ta 20h45 le président qui
arrive tout à 20h sur ces vides
[Applaudissements]
c'est le fun
et ça laisse on marche sur la tête
ces experts n'ont même pas de moi c'est
à dire il ya eu un ciel aussi c'est les
chaînes pour les enfants c'est à dire
faire il se passe n'importe quoi tu as
dragon ball z
frères ya le président maintenant et
s'il ya un truc j'ai jamais compris sur
les chaînes pourquoi ils mettent des
dessins animés à 4 heures du matin après
vo elle et l'enfant insomniaques sont
comme
annoncé quoi mais c'est vrai que c'est
qu'elle nous bouffe tu va regarder un
dessin animé à trois heures de ma faute
à papa aussi tu sais ça vous regarde à 4
heures du matin c'est quoi c'est pour
les adultes enfin c'est surtout
et ensuite
à croire j'ai eu tous les chiffres sont
à jour et j'ai eu il est passé lui à rui
un moment il est à 12
après il a fait 45 ici on apporte quoi
donc il finit à 27 27 84 et à tpm pelles
et à 31,27 il était un peu plus beaucoup
ils étaient surestimés dantec même p 27
s'attendait à rci il fait les sondages
était bon sur le web